hello there you're watching the press
preview first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what is making the headlines with
the director of the demos think tank
paulie mckenzie and the political
commentator and former government
special adviser sal michael thanks so
much both of you for joining us this
evening look forward to looking through
your choices they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight so let's see
what is on the front of some of those
papers the mail predicts that a change
to coverage travel rules will trigger
the great autumn holiday stampede
same story for the times their headline
travel boom after covert rules eased
the mirror says families are getting
ready for half-term holidays after the
major shake-up of the foreign travel
rule
senior scientific advisors claim the
government is no longer listening to
their advice at a crucial point in the
pandemic that's on the front of the
guardian
the express goes with warnings of
massive disruption to the delivery of
meat beer and fizzy drinks within days
because of a carbon dioxide shortage
the telegraph says russia has been
accused of rigging gas prices and the uk
food market could be plunged into chaos
that's also the lead story for the
financial times which reports the steel
industry could also be badly affected
the sun hears that two professional
dancers on strictly have refused to take
the covert vaccine
and the star has a story about people
not trying traditional british food like
toad in the hole because they don't
believe the dishes exist
toad in the hole is very real we're
joined tonight by polly mckenzie and
salma shah to take us through their
choices hello ladies thank you both so
much for joining us um we're going to
start this evening uh with the daily
mail
we talked a lot about covert over the
last 24 hours now it's official the
rules have been changed fewer countries
uh on that red list amber's done away
with and fewer pcr tests apollo are do
you think we are going to see a great
autumn holiday stampede as the mail says
i'm sure we will you know lots of people
did have holidays in the uk this year
because of the complexity of getting
overseas and that led to kind of
pressure on prices for uh what is still
debatable whether it's a staycation or
simply holiday in the uk but
nevertheless prices went up we had to
camp because it was literally the only
kind of holiday that we could find that
was that was available
and if the opportunity now comes because
of this unraveling of those restrictions
for more people to travel overseas
during the halftime holidays we can
expect to see that price surge again
because of course huge numbers of people
including peevish little me are stuck
unable to go on holiday and take
advantage of this except when the kids
are off so whether it is christmas or
the um the autumn half term i think lots
of people will be thinking about it if
they can the danger is of course we
don't know if case numbers will surge
and we don't know if new variants will
emerge which forced the government uh as
has you know been in the news a little
bit this week to reconsider or or pull
some of the the guidelines back in again
but for the moment yeah lots of
enthusiasm for those of those of us with
the freedom to go on holiday and i
didn't know about you sam i don't know
whether you had to endure camping as
well this summer um but but i suppose
the big question is
it's the timing of it and whether or not
it could backfire if the numbers do then
go up after the october half term
i think that's a very real concern
the issue that i think that gives
perhaps the government and certainly me
a little bit more confidence is that
case numbers haven't surged in the way
that they were expected to once the
schools had come back so we may have a
situation where actually case numbers
can be contained and the government is
feeling a little bit more confident
that's why they're releasing
international travel
i think we just heard that we are
worried about other variants that may um
may emerge as a consequence of more
movement but there is something i think
that's interesting about some of the
countries that have been taken off the
red list so you've got countries like
pakistan on there
and we know obviously it borders with
india where the delta virus variant has
been as rife
and we actually don't know what the
vaccination situation is on the ground
in countries like that so there is some
serious risk in in some of these areas
some of these choices
and polly i suppose that risk is
heightened by the fact that the pcr
tests are going to be scrapped for lots
of people which what was the test that
was able to
work out which variant people may have
been exposed to
yeah absolutely because if you take the
lateral flow test the simple one that
you just you know you can just do at
home and the line emerges to tell you
whether you've whether you've probably
got covered or not absolutely you can't
then do the dna sequencing um
simplifying this makes a lot more people
able to travel also more people able to
come to the uk
and help boost our flagging tourism
industry our hotels our hospitality so
you can understand why the government's
doing that but again i think
they have to remain
open to the idea that restrictions might
need to be tightened again however much
we might all not want that to happen
if the situation changes well then the
rules are going to have to change too
summer i mean
do you think that there was a lot of
pressure on the government from the
tourism industry
to to push to to get this reopening for
the october break
i think they've resisted pressure from
the tourism industry in the aviation
industry um
for such a long time that it doesn't
strike me as the kind of thing that they
would give into now i think a lot of it
is to do around with the fact that they
feel a new sense of confidence with the
numbers around uh cases and uh
hospitalizations
that said i think polly's absolutely
right that they can't rule out and their
language has been much more cautious
around the fact that restrictions may
come back and so there is this push to
vaccinate and certainly uh push to
vaccinate um 12 to 15 year olds and also
create this booster jab which i'm i
think that they are hoping is going to
get them through without reversing any
of these openings well we shall see we
shall see um the other story that a
couple of the of the broadsheets are
leading with the ft and the daily
telegraph
is about gas prices and and polly um the
daily telegraph's its line is russia is
accused of rigging gas prices uh the ft
saying gas crisis hits more industries
this is really going to affect us all
isn't it i mean it's gone from a story
that was maybe on the business pages
that people weren't really taking much
notice of
because our household bills are really
going to go up
well that's the first obvious
consequence of gas prices going up is
that we are very likely to see that
filter through to our own heating bills
and the way the energy price cap
operates means that you know it will
change the the pricing dynamics as well
uh compare the market for example of
withdrawn uh energy switching uh one of
the papers is reporting uh just
temporarily but whilst um whilst because
some of the tariffs have been withdrawn
and restricted and to sort of calm the
market down
but it's more complicated than that
what's fascinating
you know set out in these articles for
example
pesticide companies are being shut down
in terms of their operations because
it's too expensive because of the cost
of natural gas that's leading to a
crisis in the supply of co2 which is
likely to lead to a supply crisis in
terms of fresh meat um and and you were
reminded i think of how interconnected
all of this is and the way that energy
prices can shift so many of the
different dynamics in our economy and we
already got because of brexit because of
covid all sorts of supply chain
disruptions and so this you know
russia's behavior uh telegraph is kind
of directing it to i think it's much
more complicated than that but it adds
just another enormous dynamic which also
puts pressure on inflation which we're
experiencing as we emerge from the
crisis
which could have a huge effect on fiscal
and monetary policy if it doesn't as
most economists are predicting disappear
once we're once we're fully recovered
but it's fingers crossed really about
that and salma it is really complicated
isn't it because as paulie says it's not
just russia it's the fact that that we
possibly don't store enough uh of our
own energy as we could do in the uk and
we've also seen this fire down at this
cable plant down in kent over over the
last couple of days but
do you think
do you think it's true do you think
russia is rationing gas to europe
i i think it's probably the case that uh
this the russian state does have a huge
influence on uh what some of the
state enterprises does do
um
i mean we've obviously talked about the
complexity of what happens to uh you
know people's cost of living what
happens to supply chains but the
international dynamic is important
because this investigation that is
looking at russia's actions is
suggesting that there is uh
has been an unfair increase and this
just speaks to the fact that actually we
are living in quite uncertain global
times we are getting a little bit more
particularly within europe which has
been protected for such a long time
from these kind of like
changing dynamics uh it looks like that
is changing and there's a little bit of
instability that exists around energy in
the way that it hasn't done for a very
long time
because bollywood russia are pushing to
to get use of the nord stream to
pipeline aren't they um is this the
right way to go about it do you think
putting putting pressure on the rest of
europe
you know the political dynamics between
russia and europe are
incredibly complicated
but i think what they can see is that
because of this range of post-pandemic
inflationary pressures
because of supply chain disruption
actually putting pressure on industry
around gas supply is a profound way
potentially to secure an obvious
political advantage around a pipeline
but i think when you look at russia's
tactics in the west more broadly
actually destabilization and disruption
is more what they're interested in it's
why uh you know russian intelligence
services have been involved in
disinformation and misinformation
campaigns it's not just simple
propaganda to promote a world view it's
to try and disrupt and discombobulate
and so i i i think you know trying
trying to
sort of single out a particular motive
when it comes to russia is is actually
not um acknowledging the complexity of
the way they seek to influence the west
and of course summer also there's been a
lot of emphasis on on renewable energy
britain becoming more self-sufficient
and and generating its own energy but
we've had the double whammy this year
that actually we've not had a lot of
energy from wind turbines because it's
not been very windy
well this is always the difficulty with
renewables in that sense but there is
something else that is difficult is that
we also want to be green so we're
cutting down our coal-powered
stations
which is the right thing to do but at
the same time there's very little that's
going on in terms of infrastructure to
replace it so people are very
anti-fracking and those kind of fracking
sites that
that companies are looking at to exploit
are also very slow in coming on stream
if they will at all um so we are dealing
with a a much more unstable energy
picture in the uk
uh and you know again added to that you
know people are very nervous about
nuclear so um there don't seem to be
very many good options
we we all need to insulate our homes
don't we maybe those climate protesters
on the m25 all right we'll come on to
that possibly in the next in the next
bit welcome back you're watching the
press preview and with me now polly
mckenzie and salva shah taking us
through their choices and we we talked
about gas and renewable energy uh in the
first half and and this half we've got
an inside page from the mail and this is
about the eco protesters who've closed
down lots of the m25 uh throughout the
course of the week police finally get
tough on the eco mob as the mail
describes them polly do you think these
guys are are succeeding are they making
their point or are they alienating more
people than they're converting
it's really debatable because we have
seen over the period when extinction
rebellion has been active quite a shift
in attitudes to climate change and
people's enthusiasm and willingness
to accept even some kind of financial or
kind of regulatory burdens in order to
tackle uh climate change
nevertheless when they conduct tactics
like this i
i just can't believe
that it's not
uh alienating at least enough people to
make it harder for the government to
actually move what we really need around
climate change is to to de-escalate it
not because it doesn't matter but
because it it does and in fact you know
they're sort of turning it into a sort
of culture war and and screaming
everybody and lying down in front of
cars
just it just raises the tension instead
of us being able to have a a real debate
about the issues they're raising i mean
particular tactic i understand here is
that it's an insulation campaign they
want to insulate houses i agree with
that very important and they're lying
down in front of cars they the two are
not particularly well linked but hey
maybe maybe i just uh
wanted to be tidy in a press release or
something i know because they've held me
up a few times this week and i did want
to sort of you know shout out the window
i've lagged my pipes i've i've done my
loft let me through you know i'm one of
the good ones but but as you say it's
quite indiscriminate isn't it uh
salvador i mean
do you think that that these groups have
an important point do you do you think
that you know that that we need these
kind of groups in society or do you
think that it's just going to make the
government more dug in and that it won't
be held to ransom
i have to say i always try and be
equivocal about things like this and i
try and see the other point of view and
it's very rare that i will take a really
strong opinion on on a group like this
but i have to say i find extinction
rebellion completely and utterly
pointless
um i do think that they they alienate
people i think that their tactics are
childish i think you know we've made the
case and the world has moved into a
place where it understands
the pressures on the climate and we we
know that we are running out of time to
do stuff about it
this is not constructive this is not
something that's going to encourage
people to go out there and really change
their passions and behaviors and also
this isn't really just about you know
getting individuals to insulate their
loss this is also about a global effort
around climate change so it feels to me
that this is
slightly novelty and uh you know
designed to to get headlines but is
never really going to move
the movement on
any further okay let's just have a
little bit of light relief for the end
of the paper review and you've chosen
the front of the daily star uh it's
headlined the great british berkoff
these are apparently half wits who've
never tried traditional british grub
such as toad in the hole and largely
polly because apparently they think it
has real toads in it
well i mean they're wrong basically all
of this is sausages i mean the great
british sausage which we know has been
very controversial around brexit and
where we can transport it there is a
thousand things you can do with the
sausage but don't make spotted dick
that's cake with raisins
um people should try these things and of
course they've got stupid names i i
think the food shortages won't get so
bad though that we have to actually
resort to eating toads i have to say i
know a massive anatomy in the whole and
also do we do you know where it came
from the phrase tone in the hell
up in al mouth in northumberland a man
playing golf got a hole in one when he
went to retrieve his ball there was a
toad in the hole and they baked this
dish for him at the local pub in
celebration